what you going to what you what you have
to do dog is read that book Hey listen
man you are scared of flying man I get
it get the book as the pilot man and you
read that book and man that it's a page
and you get in the air man you be why is
your Mexican voice someone under immense
physical
strain
Runk
W hello
hello
[Music]
hello welcome the
lifeline okay yes episode 86 it's Sunday
December 3rd yeah it is and uh it's uh
look you know it's a home stretch for
the year right Christmas is coming up
you can you know what you do for
Christmas you you can get your someone
uh patreon for the lifeline luxury
patreon.com Lifeline luxury you can do
that or you can go and you can get my
special for your for your special
someone special for special someone and
that's on grow or that's on chia.com
it's my special grow or
die so what frantic frantic I was I was
just in uh traffic for do the thing I
was just in traffic for two hours um so
anyway but I'll be in uh let's see
December 3rd so I will be in well
tonight and
reading uh and then Oxnard California
I'll see you coming up soon and
Sacramento California Brea California
Phoenix uh January 20th can't wait for
that to go back to the celebrity is it
the Celebrity Theater yeah the one in
the round and uh El Paso Texas and
Albuquerque New Mexico bragging well you
know it's what it is uh got a new
podcast solo coming out not with this
fraking Jabron you know what I mean it's
called the private record uh you can
submit now to be a guest you got a crazy
story you want to come on the show tell
the world tell me and tell the world uh
go to the privat record.com and submit
yourself as a guest there we're on all
the socials Instagram Tik Tok the
private record And subscribe on YouTube
to get all the updates for when we're
going to drop episodes you got a
question click for this show click the
link in the description below heho heho
he he who or go to watch lifeline.com
okay or you can do at the hotline at the
number that I don't know top of my head
but it's just you know binging
binging you want a one-onone advice
session with me go to mata.com Bing
binging binging you want the lifeline
merch go to Lifeline
merch.com dude I don't want I don't want
my fans to come up to me at my meet and
greet saying bing bang Bing to late cuz
they do that they do that they do that
it's a it's spreading it's going viral
what do you think of uh wearing black
with light
jeans what do I think about it yeah
here's what I think about
it do you think it's okay it's [__]
yeah dude it's like you're like a dad in
of a four-year-old in 1989 when you do
that I am almost a dad of a
four-year-old and it's 20123 but I I I I
don't think you I feel that same way too
I feel like it's a dad thing to wear a
black sweater and light jeans but you're
a dad so it's all good right no no no
but but why do we think that's a dad
thing because it's like a thing that our
dad and his friends did when we were
little kids right okay yeah I I mean I
suppose so dude we had I our dad Bia is
known in the tri-state area for those
who don't know like Anthony who actually
literally just he literally just said he
thought Kansas was on the East Coast
before you walked in wow okay well okay
so people that don't know geography he's
not good with geography because he
doesn't know he lives in an awful
neighborhood too like Anthony MH doesn't
know [__] about geography thought Kansas
was on the East Coast dude like on the
actual Coast Coast yeah I guess it's
it's more I didn't say the coast Kansas
what Kanas which Kansas City though it
doesn't matter doesn't matter W that's
crazy Kansas he thought it was on the
East Coast anyway wait he thought the
State Kansas was on theast St Kansas was
on the East Coast that's how wrong he
was yeah you didn't even understand
because that's how no I didn't
understand I could uh yeah couldn't
possibly but uh my dad it turns out our
dad he's also your dad was a an icon in
the tri-state area he was a Pioneer in
wearing all black oh that's yes did you
know that no wait who said
that it was delivered to us by the
producer of the show
Chris he was told it by a the father of
someone he met when he went to college
in Ithaca which is in Upstate New York
nowhere near New Jersey where we grew up
the legend had spread so just like
Johnny Cash my my dad was a Pioneer and
wearing all black I wore all black to
the gym today and I was I was wearing
all black to the gym today and you know
that's not a thing I think about I just
had the clothes on and some guy said
looking really Armenian today someone
just came up to you and said that yep
and I was just like oh yeah I all black
I think he all I mean I only know him
from he said
like high and other things to be at the
gym you could be Armenian though like
it's not that far of a cry for you to be
I think I really don't I don't think I
look Armenian you don't but it's like
what a thing to say maybe he was
Armenian I'm not sure he could have been
Armenian oh he could have been like
Armenian Pride yes yes yes but anyway I
got the I got the dark it's actually a
grow or die what do you think competent
QVC
yeah it's cool I mean it is cool a m
stripper a male stripper what you just
why why why stuck out your butt and look
back um so it's a grower die crew neck
and it's really nice uh but you can get
you can get at chris.com but yeah so uh
I I'm wearing I'm wearing this and it
dude it I don't do you think okay so
here's how much traffic that we had
here's how much traffic that was on you
were act and you were acting like I
should have known it was going to be 2
hours and and that's not that's not
that's ludicrous you were 75 minutes
late so let's add that to the time that
you took to get here which was 40
minutes 40 minutes is an absurd amount
of time to assume it would take you to
get from the where you live I wasn't I
was about to say it but I don't want to
say it okay fine down to downtown Los
Angeles okay getting
from Silver Lake to downtown at 4 at 420
would take 40 minutes okay you were
coming from four times that distance
probably more I didn't know it was I
didn't know it was going to be that bad
I thought it would be I thought it' be
10 15 minutes when we were making a time
to come here I said it's 5:00 that's
probably the worst possible time
everyone do it yeah I'm sorry I'm really
sorry only I was on time I'm really
sorry I I I badly and dude I was in so
much traffic that I called Mom and Dad
they were sitting together though they
they they called me back they didn't
pick up either of them they both called
me back separately they were both at the
house and they both call back separately
my mom called me back hey what's going
on I say hey how's it going she was
talking we talking a little bit
10 minutes later my dad said hey did you
call yeah that's so Dad speaking of dad
[__] that is so Dad I was like yeah oh
yeah I didn't I I I I guess Mom didn't
tell you they were probably watching
[__] combat or something like that
you know what I mean what's combat that
black and white show in the 50s oh wow
remember how dad used to watch it no you
don't no I remember he used to watch
Bonanza yeah same thing that mean like
that you know not same thing obviously
different show but I would never call
banan a combat but um so yeah there was
okay so do you think Mom was like well
you know
holidays and also the holiday I like I
think it might be the rain cuz it
drizzled a little a little bit but then
mom was like oh yeah you know the
holidays too you think the holidays I
guess more people are out doing their
their stuff trying to but not right now
though it's no that's not why it's just
because it's La dude that's what La is
at 5:00 you can't get anywhere everyone
it's like everyone even people not in La
even people in Kansas all the way on the
East Coast yeah all the way on the East
Coast all the way on the Eastern
Seaboard in Kansas all the way I think
it's actually in the water Kansas is in
the water yeah it's further east than
Puerto Rico yeah Puerto Rico oh every
time I think of Puerto Rico I think of
that do you know what that is getting
poked in the butt no do you you know
what it is no it's a song let's move on
it's not it's not important but okay
brought it up anyway I'm feeling good do
you want to know anything about me or
what's up not at all this podcast is
your favorite podcast we know it is and
here's the thing we we have we have
something that we want you to do okay
tell your friend about this podcast
somebody that doesn't already listen to
the podcast spread it spread this
podcast like it's a cancer okay because
you know what I mean it's like we want
this podcast to go decades and decades
and decades don't you yeah yeah I can't
believe how many people write to me
telling me how much they love the
podcast go and it's like well prove it
you love it so much prove it okay yeah
exactly prove it dude all right so
anyway it's like uh it is what it is but
uh there is
a there is a mattress in my living
room do we have to explain
that you want me it's well is that like
going to even make any sense at all you
have to explain it yeah okay absolutely
not so how could it make sense if you've
explained it if we've talked about it
before we've done so many episodes of
the show I don't know how many inside
jokes we've explained and how many we
haven't no there's a mattress inside in
my living room right now okay so for how
many years now maybe like 25 years we've
made this joke oh oh explain the joke
yeah I I don't give a [__] about why I
think we've probably done the joke here
if it's the thing that the guy's saying
in the SN a code foress snip 300 yards
away if I say that there's a mattress in
the living room a Bullet to the Head
yeah yeah okay mattress is in mattresses
in the living room anyway saying it so
drunk There's Mattress in the living
room yeah uh why do there you go is that
what you want to know about too you want
to answer it so go ahead I mean we don't
have to talk about it but I will tell
you all right
so Kristen said said to Calvin okay so
Calvin it was like time to go to bed and
Calvin's like I want to sleep in your
guys bed we're like we can't but what do
you think would you want to sleep
downstairs in the living room she says
and I was like I was like what yeah what
yeah and Calvin goes like this yes of
course right and I was like what's going
on here yeah why and
then she the next thing I know mhm she's
bringing the mattress from our bedroom
upstairs to the living room down
mattress dude I think do you know
something that I am always dealing with
is how how much I forget how heavy
mattresses are yeah mattresses are
really heavy mattresses don't I don't
think they have to be that heavy and I
think that it's a little bit [__]
annoying that they're that heavy okay
it's like they're filled with it's like
they're always wet is how heavy they are
but they got to be that heavy to be the
more expensive they are are I know okay
so somebody one time gave me an $88,000
mattress I would never buy something
that expensive he was like I don't want
it I'd never used it I was like do I
want it of course but I had to transport
it yeah and I was like this is not a
possible thing to transport yeah so this
mattress was so heavy it must have
been uh 120k yeah right and so I I go
like you're not going to get the
inflatable CU we have an inflatable one
too that's like $10 right she's like now
we're going to bring the real mattress
down like no baby come on let's not do
this I look at Calvin and he's he's
already got some of the covers he's like
I'm helping I'm doing good I'm like the
strong person from Encanto who's a woman
that's a whole another thing but anyway
that's what he's saying and uh so I'm
like okay and we bring the mattress down
it dude it's so heavy we bring it
downstairs put it in the living room she
moves all the furniture and we're
watching TV and now like I can't do
anything else all day the next day
because we don't put it back because
it's too heavy to bring it back up which
is me and
her disaster this is like a I would have
this nightmare
But but so the sleeping part was super
fun Calin was there we were in the
living room it's been there for 3
days so our bedroom is a living room I
mean that's kind of cool but good luck
getting it back but here's the other
thing last night get it back get movers
I know so last night David was over and
he was like oh that's a mistake right
there and we were hang we were watching
that show [__] face off you know with
the with the Hollywood makeup [__] and
all that not not the Nicholas cting no I
don't know that and uh thankfully and
Christ was like I want to go to bed and
I was like David's over and she's like I
know but I got to
sleep but we're in the live this is the
living room
now why wasn't his mattress taken to the
living room who's Calvin Calvin not
David Smaller it's small David suvan it
would have taken a long got you yeah cuz
it's smaller and we wouldn't have
fit okay anyway that's that's the news
and you came here for the news and
that's great that's just I have so many
questions I'm not even going to ask you
know what I mean do you want to just get
into it all right
okay hey Chris and Matt uh um so this
isn't a question this is actually just
advice for Chris uh I'm wearing hats cuz
I think you would I think you would look
good in baseball hats um but the secret
is that you need to get Dad caps instead
of no regular baseball caps so ones that
have like the soft front instead of the
hard but it's not it's not the secret
for for you yeah like the I don't have a
hat to show you but ah you should have
brought a hat theill but sell this idea
came up with
um I think it'll look better on you and
then also experiment with the angle of
where it's at Up and Down Let Your Hair
do some stuff coming around it I think
you just also have to get used to
yourself in hats yeah I mean I
understand not look good in hats but the
more I wore them um and people tell me
you look pretty good in that hat I'm
like nobody said nobody ever said that
you do it Chris hey dude you know what
I'm sorry I didn't want to interrupt
your meal but you look pretty good in
that hat beanies I look like a
are T but
yeah you look really good in that hat
pretty good in that hat yeah dude I
nobody's ever said that to anyone in the
world actually nobody you look pretty
good in that hat people have said you
look really good in that hat nobody's
ever said you look pretty good in that
saying it's just not a thing to say
nobody ever said that the other thing is
um it makes everything he said totally
toss out the window I don't think that
he uh
knows okay let me just say this dad hat
look actually worse on me they do they
look worse they look worse on me if I
the only ball cap I could possibly wear
is one straight up that like you know
Jay buer wears for for work wow yeah so
Jay buer dude wow you know um I'm just
not a ha guy and I'm fine with it I
don't need to be a ha guy I don't care
about it you know what hats itch my
[__] head how about that I don't know
how people wear hats all day I I don't
understand how be a wear hats all day
you wear hat all day uh yeah actually
more now than I used to and it doesn't
bug you uh it it it's like does it bug
me no it doesn't bug me now it really it
it doesn't just bug me it really really
well that's the kind of thing it's like
growing a beard everyone's like you know
it itches it itches how do you grow that
beard it itches dude if you have a beard
you think I'm just itchy all day M
doesn't itch at all [__] maniacs like
I'm not like doing it even though it
itches a lot obviously it grows past a
certain point and it doesn't itch
anymore but it doesn't even itch even at
any point for me I I never have an itchy
beard I've never I yeah I know but if
you what I'm saying is if you don't ever
have a beard and you start to grow one
it itches in that initial period oh not
to me but you always have a beard that's
what I'm saying if you don't always have
a beard and then you decide to grow one
it itches last time I shaved it was 3 I
was 36 well that's 17 years ago years no
s years ago and then the time before
that I was 31 so I've shaved my beard
twice in 13 years and that's no joke so
then there there in lies the reason you
never have an itchy beard it didn't itch
when I grew it out those two times wow
I'm pissed I'm pissed but that's the
truth dude but you shaved it and then it
grew right back yeah that's what I'm
saying dude you are not listening John
malovich you are not [__] listening
what do you mean I'm not
listening what do you mean what do you
mean that's what you're saying you're
saying what if you always have a beard
and then you shave it and grow it back
it doesn't itch if you never have a
beard I'm only saying the thing I've
been
get I get it saying the enti time I
don't know if okay I don't know if
you've been specifically saying that but
okay okay okay fair enough all right but
I don't look good in hats I have been
specifically saying thate please rewind
to find out I'm not I'm also not I'm I
don't look good in hats I'm also not
going to try yeah don't bother and I'm
good I'm good I also I'm lucky I have
good hair I'm happy I'm good good and
rate my hair worked out for everybody
today yeah six and a half dude you're a
real stinge you know that then why do
you ask dude last time you asked I said
the truth it was a nine I gave you the
[__] honest [__] it looked
good I think it's oh it looked better
from the side seven and a half so so
from the side seven and a
half turn straight on six yeah six and a
half yeah but that that is good this
this is an eight yeah okay so it's up
now all right yeah no it looks really
good from the from the back like this uh
seven the funniest thing would be if you
said 10 but okay that's fine I set you
up for I don't [__] around with ha for a
really funny joke I just give you the
honest [__] dude I don't care how good a
joke can be I'm honest about him all
right all right uh all right let's do
the next one what's up guys a common
interaction for me is that somebody will
reference a movie from call it 1970 to
2000 now this isn't a big deal in itself
right we're having a conversation you're
welcome to reference whatever movie you
want but I wasn't raised on film my
parents didn't care about movies so I
haven't seen all these sort of classic
American films from before the turn of
the Millennia and so inevitably have to
be like hey I don't understand your
reference I haven't seen that movie and
then the person's like oh oh you haven't
seen that movie dude you got to see it
it's the best movie like oh yeah and I'm
like no it was made in 1983 and it's
actually not good anymore you just have
an association with it yes right and
well that's wrong I actually really take
it anymore because
every time the reaction is the same when
I haven't seen a person's favorite movie
you know and it's just like I'm not I
don't really need advice on how to spin
move out of this like I [__] you know
put somebody down but I know you guys
are film Buffs so I wanted to get your
opinion on are these people in the right
for flaming me or am
I right to stand tall in the fact
that the camer eat the camera going to
become the camera
and then we see yeah and then we see
nothing so the answer is you're not
wrong if you don't care about movies who
gives this [__] yeah but he's saying
though like should I have should I watch
these movies answer no not if you don't
care about you obviously don't care
about movies you weren't raised on
movies you don't watch movies that are
old like from before now so like why
would you give a [__] it's annoying that
they do that but like I don't know I I
love movies I don't even do that who are
these people you know what though it it
really does happen no matter how many
movies you've seen I've seen a lot of
movies and there's movies that I just
like it Haven I haven't seen Step
Brothers you haven't seen Step
Brothers but like I said this the other
day and people lost their mind like I
can't just live a life and not see step
brother let me tell you something that's
going to crack your mind open okay and
the truth is going to alter your per of
reality oh okay you've seen step brother
people I have seen I do I have all these
memories of it okay what but for real
though okay people like actual film
Maniacs okay would never do that see do
what do the what this guy's saying they
they're they're yes because they know
that they're [__] maniacs and they're
not like expecting everyone else to be
like that the only people that do that
are [__] losers who seen like 10
movies from every decade and they think
they're some [__] expert cuz they've
seen Fletch that might be true okay so
those people the ones that flame you for
not seeing [__] City Slickers are
just [__] they should call them theid
Fletch wandering around yeah Fletch
[__] sucks Fletch sucks yeah but
people that have seen Fletch are like
you haven't seen Fletch yeah that movie
should be called wandering why would
they do that cuz he's just walking
around like like looking in drawers
that's all he does if well that would be
better he's at the beach and [__] that
would be better sometimes yeah dude it
sucks and then they try to make a remake
with John Ham did I didn't see it did
you see it they did did you see it I
didn't even know that that was didn't
see it dude I didn't even know that was
a thing that alone did I see it John Ham
did it yeah okay well it's crazy CU I
was
like man if that was if they remade
Fletch like in 2000 with somebody it
would be a big deal but now just nobody
gives a [__] I mean I even yeah I mean
there's a movie there's movies that I
don't even know M that I should
absolutely know exist but I dude even
I'm just like movies are so I don't
[__] give a [__] anymore you know
they remade Rocky two years
ago get it yeah I mean they basically
did whated Creed yeah well that's the
spinoff but what was what what was the
Fletch remake called
wandering for no John Ham I don't know
flet wander I don't even know this back
in Action Fletch whoopsy Daisy who the
called fletch it has called got be
called something lives yeah yeah yeah
was the sequel that they made in the80s
no with John Ham no not Fletch 2 he
writes you know [__] unre writes
Fletch [__] two do you believe this
guy I don't Fletch was a hit obviously
there's a two and it's obviously not the
John Ham one bro it's called confess
Fletch yeah [__] Fletch [__] you hold
on but we're not even doing you got to F
for Fletch two already [__] exists
and it was made in the ' 80s of course
he wouldn't know that he thinks Kansas
is underneath Connecticut
he literally thinks Kansas is right
above [__] Florida
okay the bigger thing is it's confess
Fletch okay why is that a thing that's
the worst [__] title ever okay well
even heard of flet good for you honest
good for you you haven't seen Fletch no
the M no it's fine you haven't heard of
Fletch it's fine it's good dude [__]
that's progress somebody hasn't heard of
fles that's [__] it's a movie in the
80s that was by Chevy Chase Chevy Chase
is very funny and he's in it and he
plays like this you know detective
that's like you know silly but getting
the job done kind
ofb he's a smart guy but uh yeah and it
it's bad it's really bad and people who
have seen 12 movies from the 80s are
like you haven't seen flash lives yeah
shut the [__] up you okay well I got you
deserve to burn in [__] out that's a
bit extreme and uh we're going to lose
subscribers for that but um I was I came
home the other day and Kristen was
watching White Christmas the movie with
Danny Kay and Bing Crosby right cool
cooler than flet 1950 something let me
tell you something dude movies were
[__] different and that movie sucked
well those movies definitely sucked I on
34 Street straight up one shot for
[__] 12 minutes and and he was just
like well darling we're both sitting on
a bench how do you expect it was going
to go you're watching the wrong [__]
I'll give you some [__] from Matthew I
your [__] nuts into your [__]
[__] losing subscribers so listen
I'll give you some [__] that'll blow
your nuts down [__] throat out your
[__] ass you have a nut sack ass dude
I mean bleep that all okay so but um
anyway uh it was terrible White
Christmas was terrible and uh I can so
you think movies can be good 70 years
later yeah they can well I know they can
yeah I mean I can list them up but I
don't want to be boring as hell [__]
Shore I don't want to be boring as
[__] [__] unlike this guy's friends
you haven't seen Kaza Blanca that movie
probably Su new friends dude all right
that's the solution well that's the
advice I got for you okay you want to
see another one I mean not saying words
M all right another one hey Chris and
Matt so just went to the mechanic and
the guy who's working on my car um had a
lazy eye and I've came I've come into
this problem multiple times in the past
don't really know where to look when I'm
talking to them obviously trying not to
look at their lazy eye um or maybe I
should look at their lazy eye or should
I look at just their one good eye or
should I look at both eyes or pretend
like I'm looking at both eyes I feel
like that's what I usually do with
people that have two good eyes um so
just trying to figure out how to make
this not weird for him for me and
everything in between um I know also
side note uh this guy wanted to shake my
hand after we met for an estimate and
his hands were absolutely filthy I uh
didn't want to shake them but I did
because I didn't want to make things
weird
so I shook them I sucked it up I've
gotten my hands dirty before doing
things so I understand it's not a huge
deal um but the thing that IRS me the
most is he held on so tight and for so
long and so
disgusting what do you do in that
situation here's first of all here's
what you when someone with a lazy eye
goes to shake your hand there's only one
thing to do give me your
hand and that's it all
right how could you not do that that's
what they would do what that you're
saying that's I know but obviously you
can't undo them extending their hand
right okay you can't go back in time and
change someone else's actions so you do
that and then they go what the [__] oh
that must be my fault you make they
laugh because they have a lazy eye well
but okay and they get the joke and you
laugh and then you [__] shove their
nuts down their throat come right out
their ass bleep it out I don't think
that honestly that that
would be happen once even I don't think
dud the guy with a lazy eye would
appreciate it and he would say you know
what thank you I've been looking all my
life for that I'm not saying they
wouldn't appreciate it what I'm saying
is if you go like this if if a lazy I go
like that and then you put your hand
there I think zero of them would laugh
and and and know what was happening that
you were making a joke I think you don't
think you don't think they would know
what I no not if you haven't talked
about the lazy eye dude but everybody
knows he got a lazy eye he has a lazy
eye it's not something you need to talk
about so picture this you have a lazy
eye all right you it's not new to you
you've had one you're 40 you're not
thinking of it every day all the time
and someone does that you think what the
[__] wrong with this guy here I am
correct here here lies the answer to his
Vi about the lazy
eye he's not thinking about it he's had
the lazy forever that's what I just said
I know I just said here in lies the
[__] answer to his question okay okay
okay okay oh oh to him okay I know you
just said I thought you were facing me
all right I thought you giving him he
doesn't think about his lazy eye doesn't
matter where you look he he's had it for
[__] ever and ever yeah okay he
doesn't give a [__]
he's got a lazy eye [__] hates it I
got even better I have better advice
okay wear
sunglasses oh so you see a guy with okay
you're wearing regular glasses oh [__]
oh [__] yeah right yeah okay yeah hey
sir he puts his out you still did the
thing yeah dude that's exactly right
that's what you should do yeah or check
or do like this or go like this oh check
this out no look what's up man yeah or
just do what what uh I do which is look
off to the side of their eyes or
anywhere else cuz I don't like looking
people in the eye what about why don't
you look
at right in between their eyes that's a
good idea look at their like the bridge
of their nose but I think I think what
he's trying to he's he's overthink I
I've never thought about this in my life
as lazy I don't even think about here's
the truth of the matter you're
overthinking it the advice is you're
overthinking it it doesn't matter where
you look he doesn't care where you look
so if you're trying to save his feelings
about feeling stupid or whatever for
having a lazy eye he doesn't feel stupid
for having a lazy eye he just has one he
doesn't care doesn't matter where you
look the end correct worst children's
book yeah yeah okay it doesn't matter
where you
look yeah that's that's that's the
advice and about the dirty hand do the I
meant to say the end I had a complete
malfunction okay well it happens Jesus
Christ now the thing about the hand is
leading me to believe that you got
problems in general because you don't
know you're you're panicking about where
to look cuz the lazy ey you don't want
to touch his hand cuz's he's a mechanic
dude of course his hands are dirty yeah
go to therapy you go to a mechanic and
you think all right I'm going to have to
watch my hands after this because you
might you're going to touch something
disgusting also I don't here's here's
the thing dude I don't mind dirty hands
yeah who cares I don't mind dirty hands
what I mind is clammy hands that's I
thought he was going to say that when
somebody has clammy hands here's the
deal if you have if you're a person and
I don't mean if you have clamy hands
sometimes but if you're a person who on
the regular has clamy hands cuz that's a
thing it's a real thing if that happens
to you don't ever [__] Shake anyone's
hand because that sucks dude I got a
buddy who he man it is crazy like I
don't even know how he dates I know who
you're talking about yeah and you go hey
what's up and oh no dude and sometimes
you know who's going to have the claming
hands too you're like no no no don't do
it bro don't do it bro all right okay
well nice to meet you great well great
great I knew it too how about those
people who are like expect you to
understand that they don't like to shake
hands so they'll just give you a fist
dude that there's nothing worse than
that well I I do be in the world I do
that be in the world shake their hand
no well okay what about me I and this is
the truth I do meet and greets all the
time I meet 100 people after every show
I don't shake hands and when I stopped
doing that I got sick I can't even tell
you how exponentially less it's
unbelievable and I don't know if it's
because of that well it definitely is I
you know no I I I would I would be sick
on the road stop shaking people's hands
I just go boom boom boom and then some
people go and I'm like and they go and I
go what you gonna do yeah it's called
the how mandal but Denny always says to
me he's like man I can't believe it's
really inspiring how much you hold out
for that I go I I don't stop yeah you're
going to do it you don't go ah okay like
you're you got to stick to it but if
somebody's like disabled or something I
might do it sure okay like if they had a
lazy eye no not that disabl it would
have to be something with their body
like in a wheelchair well yeah I would
do it for sure with that but or like
even if they had a limb like a bat one
okay okay where's the threshold what
what's not what's just not enough of a
disability for you to hold
out probably a limp but not a bad
limp like a knee problem like a a bad
KNE like like I can't tell if it's a
knee problem or if you're legs actually
way shorter if if your leg was way
shorter you would I would probably have
to do the Open Hand thing yeah but you
would begrudgingly do it no no cuz no
you said I would have to made me think I
would have I would be like okay I
understand that this is the the thing
here I got to do it you know wouldn't
make him feel bad because already he's
going through some [__] okay but just
like the lazy eye he's probably not
thinking about his [__] leg you but I
I will also uh if they had like
something like really [__] up with
their maybe mouth here's the thing about
people with [__] like I know you're
[__] I mean maybe you're being
serious but like lazy eye leg shorter
than the other joking they don't give a
[__] anymore that they have it the only
times they the only people that give a
[__] are you right so do everybody a
favor and stop ing cuz that's going to
make everybody feel better I had a I had
a friend who had uh one of those like
hands that was like smaller and like you
know and um he was at this party and I
went with my old roommate I mean this
was a long time ago to the party and I
said hey what's up bro said hi to him I
slapped his his hand MH his little hand
and my roommate goes hey man how's it
going so we we have the party whatever
we leave we're in the car and he's like
hey man you don't give me like a heads
up that the guy had like a small hand
and I was like oh yeah you know what I I
definitely should have oh really well
here's why I should have because I don't
want the guy with the hand to feel any
weird thing like with what if the guy
went whoa you know what I'm saying yeah
so I should have been like yo by the way
you can shake some guy's hand he's going
to have a small hand let me ask you
though the guy with the hands uhhuh was
it his party or something no but did you
know you were going to see him there how
could you give give him a heads up if
you didn't know he was going to be there
well I saw him you see him hey buddy
just so you know this guy's got the
hands thing hey man got a small hand he
you do it it's just like it says like
what does your other friend expect don't
jump don't jump don't know what I mean
when I say yeah how it going how
conscientious does he want you to be
that's ridiculous oh [__] dude he man
keep it together you know what I mean
when you say how you doing good to see
you Adam all right Adam you
know um yeah I don't remember if I knew
too much for him to expect if you're
going to the GU party and like your
friend that you're going that you're
bringing has never met him You' be like
hey just so you know this is going on
with this guy's hands but like if you
just see him run into it you don't have
time to be like guys what's up hey how's
it going oh uh give us one second yeah
yeah it doesn't work hi how's it
going yeah it doesn't work doesn't work
in real time you're right all right
next what's up Matt what's up Chris
big dog here big dog I forgot to mention
completely in the first submission that
I've talked to my girlfriend multiple
times about her brother and as much as
it pisses me off more importantly it
makes her so uncomfortable oh and
whenever she goes into a situation where
she's going to be in one of these
interactions um she just has ter so this
was last episode oh yeah okay we got so
so this guy big dog this is a huge
Revelation it could have been two
episodes ago but he said that he has a
problem with how much affection his
fiance or girlfriend or wife's uh uh
brother how much affection his brother
shows her right how much affection her
own brother shows her shows her and we
were like well is that their thing or
whatever or like have you talked to her
about it so he's clearing this up for us
and saying it makes her uncomfortable
which we did not know that we were not
pry to that information we didn't know
that it made her uncomfortable which is
something for sure definitely tell us
you should dude look come on Bigg you
look like my friend from high school
Matt Hannah and you should have you
should have told us this important
detail which is that your girlfriend
also [__] hates it look big dog big
dog you don't come with us with a little
bit of information you want to be big
dog you want big dog you come a whole
[__] you come with with a [__]
dosier a proper big dog would have told
us the entire picture bring the dossier
yeah all right all right so anyway big
dossier for Big Dog yeah anxiety and
doesn't know what to do and she was
actually the one seeking the advice and
I kind of dropped the ball with my
delivery on the whole thing making it
kind of seem like it was just my problem
um but yeah definitely she's
uncomfortable we're still seeking advice
we got a little bit of a update uh not a
full resolution yet but yesterday she
went and talked to her dad had the
awkward conversation um just kind of
seeking refuge in her dad uh saying what
she feels how it makes her uncomfortable
the things that she finds weird the dad
completely took the brother's side and
said that she shouldn't be feeling this
way uh she needs to get more comfortable
with it all because he loves her more
than anybody else in the whole entire
world made it a little weirder on top of
that he pointed out that she is her
brother's phone
wallpaper bro what just a picture of her
it gets weirder and weirder as the days
go on regardless we're about 2 days away
from Thanksgiving and I think I'm going
to have to just sack up and pull him to
the sideline and give him a Stern
talking to because at this point she's
really expressing that it makes her
really uncomfortable and she doesn't
want to be in these situations
regardless I just wanted to clear that
up a little bit um but love you guys
between the last submission and this
submission I watched this special 10 out
of 10 some of your best work yet thank
you bro I'll call you next week with an
update and we'll see what's going on
dude we would love ribs yeah buddy we
would love an update this is really
interesting what if it was like and at
the end the dad wanted to give her
dude I don't it's it's twisted at this
point if the dad is like you got to be
okay with this little girly like little
like little girlly you got to be okay
with the how much the brother loves you
so demented little girl you got to be
okay with basically what he said though
dude dude no that is not cool man hold
on hold on let's look at this from a
different lens okay I agree it's very
weird and it needs to stop okay but the
father could just be what you know
Old-Timers and [__] they're like I don't
want there to be a problem look just
just it's your brother relax you know
what I'm saying it's still bad but he
needs to respect how she feels but you
know oldtimers bro Old-Timers are like
hey it's fine how's the weather you know
it could be a little of that okay but if
I'm if I'm the dad mhm and my daughter
comes to me and says your son my brother
is making me uncomfortable with how
touchy feely he is with me and like
possessive he is of me me uh when I I
see him it makes me
uncomfortable the very first thing I do
knock knock her out is oh no oh yeah is
roundhouse sweep her legs so she falls
on her [__] ass and says never talk
about family like that again no I would
call
him right and say hey man what's this
I'm hearing like what what why are you
making your sister uncomfortable what
the [__] are you doing yeah or have him
talk to you both yeah be like hey guys
gather around what's going on here it's
like a it's like the thing about is it's
a physical [__] up physical thing like
that is a no no dude you can't be doing
that [__] and it doesn't even matter if
the even if I don't believe this but
even if she was being what one might
call like over sensitive that doesn't
matter either you're making someone
uncomfortable you have to stop doing
that right for the dad to take the
brother's side to me is [__] demen
well here's the deal you're it's this is
going to end up in a Hulu documentary
and you know it is it's going to end up
in a Hulu Hulu docu series Hulu you know
Hulu docu series then and somebody's
going to die and it sucks and it's going
to be like the family secrets and all
the way back then it's going to have old
old time pictures of the dad you know
what I mean and you're [__] so so just
make sure you get a good deal from Hulu
basically is what I'm
saying yeah and if they make a movie
Hopefully the guy from Reacher can play
you you know that guy's pretty cool you
know you look like him a little bit uh
but yeah big dogs got to be big dog and
and step I'm sure you said something at
Thanksgiving so let us know how please
let us know dude also hilarious to C how
big dog and have a [__] framed
picture of a lion yeah we I think we
know a lot about this guy at this point
and that's the and and just by the way
bud that's the worst picture you can
have in your house so anyway a really
really really dumb buddy thing to have
framed on your wall in your home andless
buddy it's all good and even if it may
not be framed I don't know I may I saw
it wrong either way it's wor possible
you so and that's fine big dog but uh
it's all good just a lion dude just a
lion like in Shadows you know blacked
out behind it
just MH you know Big Dog hey big dog
here big cat behind me anyway um he's in
a big [__] animals dude that's it
yeah this is a [__] zebra in his
kitchen there's a big zebra here it's
all smelly and [__] hey how crazy are
zebras huh crazy that zebras are just
like still doing that [__] with the
white and black stripes you know what's
really crazy are insane are super pigs
yo dude you know about super pigs yes I
do why are you acting like I've been
bringing this up every day of your life
no I it's this is not what I'm that's
that's not how I'm reacting and you'll
understand once I explain it let the
zebra thing breathe you know you talk
about zebras for a little bit and you
have the the super big thing in the back
of your head big animals and you bring
it up a little bit later after we talk
about the white and black of the zebra
dude the White and the black of the
zebra is pretty [__] crazy yeah it is
crazy right yeah yeah yeah that's all I
wanted yeah all right now what's to talk
about Super Pig super pigs there's
nothing in history do people you want
more upsetting than Super Pig Anthony
look up Super Pig do you want to talk
about what a super pig is or you came
across it um it's not a superer uncle
was talking about it of course he was
yeah cuz he's obsessed with really V if
there's a bigger animal that should be
something is Uncle Mike will talk about
it if an animal dies Uncle Mike will
talk about it if anything about an
animal pretty much Uncle Mike will talk
about it so look at this Canadian super
pigs threaten to invade the US like like
they're a [__] terrorist group which
which they are look at them dude they're
so slow Bears B yeah just call them a
bear at that point they're [__] look
how ugly they are dude they look like
jacked UPS steroid it out regular pigs
that already have rolled around in [__]
with the NBC News logo on it you know
like it's an anchor um coming to you
live from the
pen uh look at these things yeah they're
huge everybody going to act like they've
heard of super pigs before nobody's
heard of super pigs all you people
listening right now watching right now
you've never heard of Super Pig oh dude
when I was in rehab I was in uh with a
super Pig I was no super big was my
doctor and uh no when I was in rehab
there was I was in um they had these
these pigs that were on the actual place
[__] a and you'd see them dude and
they would just be like out be walk in
your [__] bunk late at night and you
you just hear like and you look and be
like and dude they were like this
they're called Havas look up Havalina Mr
Havalina Mr have havina you know Mr
duina anyway I digress but um so um
that's funky Homo Sapien but it's all
good so the Havas and the hav
knots pic's dude the Havas and the hav
Google something and then a whole other
thing comes up that's pretty crazy huh
that is pretty crazy that's what they
had yep these are scary too yeah but
they're not as big but they're they're
[__] scary nothing that bulbus should
have those short little of legs oh God
this P you know I mean it's no wonder
why all the ancient religions are like
don't [__] with pork like they look
demonic dude yeah they do actually
you're right you're right but so um
they're [__] filthy animals old timey
movie no pul fiction that's like
literally the dialogue from p pig is a
filthy animal no I know but yeah you're
filthy animal like that's a black and
white thing that's Home Alone yeah okay
well you know exposing me but it's a
movie clip it's a fake from old movie a
movie oh it's a fake movie yeah is that
a fake movie it's a fake movie that's a
fake movie in Home Alone hold on hold on
one second hold on second how do you
know this yeah that's crazy he doesn't
know he doesn't even know that died
looked it up he [__] thought looked
up he looked when did you look I believe
that he looked it up I believe that he
looked it up but that's crazy it's
called something
uh a a Super Pig Tim Allen hold on it's
called dude what is it called um angels
with even filthier you just had it up
Anthony just had it up and he Lo lost it
oh trust me Anthony had the wrong thing
up go ahead that was home alone too D
like Oh no you're right look scroll down
be better at it be better at it scroll
down right there the story behind Home
Alone fake gangster movie Angels not
angles look at
that no it's
Angels Angels that's what I said Ang
filthy souls yeah that's it yeah nice
okay and they shot stuff for that movie
that is very cool to know that is cool
and you did look it up and I you know I
apologize thank you okay I apolog the
first time in history thank you you were
right thank you super pigs again anyway
uh yeah they have Havas and they be
there was one time where I tried to
stare one down you know that was a bad
idea probably and it just goes and I
[__] ran
into it didn't do [__] except move a
little bit and like but it's like so
abrupt you don't stare down any animal I
was you when you're out there and you're
doing it you're doing all the
self-reflective work you're thinking
about the [__] you're like dude I got
I'm one with nature I'm going to [__]
this pig up okay anyway I got scared it
me and Mike another he was I was with a
[__] Navy Seal in rehab mean both we
we ran away a n SE ran away from a
little Havalina yeah and he's killed
people wow probably all right well next
video hey Chris and Matt my name is
Briley and I'm 29 years old I live in a
really small town in Oklahoma and I am
single I want a husband one day I want
children one day so I'm asking you guys
for advice on how do I find that kind of
person um me living in a small Town
doesn't really offer me many options and
the closest Big City to me is an hour
and a half away so any wisdom or advice
would be great I will say I've tried the
app thing hasn't really offered me too
many options again with my distance from
a nearest Big City being an issue but
any help or advice you guys could give
me I would really appreciate it thanks
yeah
okay could somebody get me water if all
you if what you're looking for more than
any anything else is a family and like
just to settle down if that's at the
very top of your
list going on apps is not the right way
to do it thanks dude unless it's like
one of the what what's the one that's
been around forever that's like no no no
not not the [__] one e-harmony like one
like that where it's like it's
specifically to find Partners not [__]
buddies right right right on apps in
general people are just trying to [__]
or lie or some [__] up thing right but
e-harmony is like an actual place where
people meet and marry uh so if that's
what you want go to different apps and
the ones you're probably on but also
criteria you might want to be looking
for more than anything else is someone
who's already been married and maybe
even already has a kid because they're
not looking like just [__] around and
like hump and run they're like I did I
did it and it didn't work out but like I
know I learned learn my [__] and I I I I
know what's I know what's what I don't
want to [__] up again and I'm like I'm
serious you know what I'm saying hump
and run dude you don't want to hump you
don't want a guy who wants to hump and
run no hump and run from
Mattel the worst the worst toy that
would be in the 90s you know what I mean
oh man she humped
Bo hump and run
hey this one they go and the dice go
wow what's
that but I understand who your emotion
was oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah those
are cool hum been Ron what do you think
man honestly
dude I I've we I feel like we've gotten
this question before I dude you does she
have a kid no she no I mean no she would
have said so just move you I mean that
was the I'll be honest that was the
first thing I thought it's it's just
like and that's drastic but it is
drastic but damn you're you're you're in
the middle of nowhere in Oklahoma you're
realizing it running up against the wall
the options are limited and you if if
it's what you want more than anything D
you got to you got to you got to get out
of there I mean dude people live like up
in northern Alaska and [__] it's like if
you can't find somebody you got to move
like that's you can't live there if if
you want a family and you're not and and
everyone else is either married or she's
already 29 too in in Oklahoma they get
married at like [__] 19 12 yeah no
but for real though it's it's it's true
that
like I don't think that there's option
you don't what you don't want to do is
settle for some [__] just cuz he's close
that's the worst possible thing just
have a kids yeah and then you just
you're dead you're basically dead even
though you're still only 29 years old
you know it's drastic but um yeah move
or move to the next you know move to I
don't know where you are in Oklahoma
move move 90 minutes away to the city
there's mid Midland no that's Texas
there's Mid City that's that's in
Oklahoma Mid City which is terrible but
at least it's a bigger city there's
Kansas all the way on the East Coast
that's too far that's 2,000 miles to the
east all right next one yeah move you
got him you got probably got a yo yo I'm
Thor what's up oh it's Thor hey I'm
Chris Hemsworth what's up hey I
definitely surf what's up what's up SE
guy before
uh I called in once before I was the guy
I was like Al and didn't ask you guys a
question uh cuz I was just being goofy
dumbass um but I have a serious question
this time I don't think you guys have
covered it uh I live on Maui I fly to a
wah all the time and I fly to the
mainland to see my son um I'm 40 years
old uh I still get scared every [__]
flight um especially on
Landing uh Maui
especially and aahu they're both very
bumpy Landings uh it's very windy here I
just can't get over it I can't [__]
get over it you know unless I'm drunk or
something but that's I don't drink
anymore
so uh what do I
do Slappy Cakes it says on his shirt
here's what you do a fake place in a
movie with Adam in an Adam Sandler movie
work at Slappy cake no the a production
company Adam
s Slappy Cakes Productions uh all you
got to do
is go read this book called ask the
pilot buy a Pilot named Patrick Smith
and it will make you yeah yeah it's a
book that is specifically about why you
shouldn't be afraid to fly written by a
pilot who's flown many many many flights
yeah you read it no but I'm not afraid
of flying but I know people who are who
read it and and aren't anymore really
yeah did you just Google what it was no
I it was recently in text I wanted to
scroll back and find it yeah wow yeah uh
also you can like I mean if you have
that bad of an anxiety you can take a
[__] pill while traveling I mean it's
not yeah and also you have a good reason
for it so you can have a doctor that
will give them to you and especially if
you're flying that often like that is a
valid reason a doctor would write you a
prescription I guess my question is you
if you're doing it all the time you
don't get used to it like I used to be
kind of scared now I don't think about
it cuz I go so much yeah I mean Slappy
Cakes get scared what are you going to
do I don't think that we're going to be
be able to save Slappy Cakes we need to
enter the
contest I mean that that's the movie you
know yeah well look I think that you're
a giant [__] I think that's the
solution
no so stop being that I don't know it's
that's tough though man it's tough it's
weird to be exposed to something that
much and not not have it quell the fear
but sometimes people just so Mexican how
said sometimes sometimes you know you
just have to you know get up on the air
dog dude be careful Anthony's Mexican
sometimes be careful dude Anthony's
Mexican so then he gets it be careful
dude I got to make sure that you're
flying in the ha
dog uh hey dog look man what you got to
what you what you have to do dog is read
that book Hey listen man you are scared
of flying man I get it get the book as
the pilot man and you read that book and
man that is a page and you get in the
air man you be why is your Mexican voice
someone under immense physical
strain cuz they're LIF in a a
refrigerator or something oh you know
they so you're doing mexan or movers
yeah hey hey
dog you scared the why man yeah it's
like that well you get the book called
as P so stupid man that's what you get
and it will kill you of it okay let's go
get the Hut dude that's the kind of
voice that you would do and then not
realize it but by the time you're done
see spots yeah you'd be hurting yourself
yeah one time I was doing ADR M which
for people that don't know it's like the
background voices of movies it actually
was for my movie and I was simulating
the sounds of having sex uhhuh and it
was like a 90-minute queue and I was and
I was like 90 minute Q 90 second the
whole movie the whole movie mov was
called
[__] 90c q and by the end I literally
like my knee buckled I almost fell could
you dude seeing that would be so funny
like yeah yeah dude
it it was that though it was literally
that I'm going
under it was that that yeah and dude I
was even thinking I can't I can't
[__] pass out here I can't pass out
so you were aware it was happening no
only right at the end of the
queue so quick yeah yeah yeah oh my God
I was to in character you know cuz I'm
like that as an actor you were just in
it yeah you had a full-fledged boner
yeah I was
naked um sounded Engineers were just
like cut well that's funny dude yeah
almost passed out uh
yeah and we're done just like and just
like that the show's over no no I don't
think so I didn't I sometimes I I'm
trying to think of how I almost passed
out once when I got my blood drawn I got
up and walked out of the hospital and as
I was walking out of the hospital you
got be careful I I had to sit down and
if the chair wasn't there I would have
hit the ground but I kind of sat and
fell in the chair I only passed out
truly passed out one time and it was
when I had a really bad fever I made the
mistake of thinking running to the
toilet and forcing out my pee would be
better because I'd be on my feet for L
time wow that is such a dumb oh I was 12
yeah so I did it and in the middle of my
pee I just completely lost all
Consciousness and the only thing that
woke me up was the sound and feeling of
my bottom row of my teeth hitting the
rim of the toilet if this is the rim of
the toilet it was just like and I
bounced you're lucky didn't [__] your oh
dude I remember that kind I kind of
remember that it woke me up though if I
didn't with one of these as you were
running yeah but I mean this is the
dumbest thing ever this couldn't have
been Dumber sit down I think about that
[__] man when you're like Calvin the
other day like he was on the what do you
call it the um Ottoman and he was
jumping from the ottoman to the mattress
that we had in the living room and he
was jumping and then he wanted to try
something where you know it was like
this much distance between the Ottoman
and the The Mattress he wanted to try
where he just kind of like leaned and
like fell off the ottoman like not
jumping and he did it and his face hit
the mattress which wasn't the thing that
hurt but his back Scorpion and like he
was like oh my back and like he just
didn't know that that was going to
happen and that is like so something
that a three-year-old like obviously we
would be like oh you don't do that cuz
you're going to scorpion you know but he
he I I watched it happen and I was no
God God you know it's like that kind of
[__] that that [__] I hate as a dad
because it's like it's going to happen
but yeah you got to let him get hurt
it's bet I know don't but it's better
even don't let him get hurt [__] him up
a little bit first so you don't even
have to let him get you don't have to
worry about it so beat him yeah no just
like throw him down on the ground I
think that's bad but you know scorpion
it on purpose hey here's a scorpion kid
no I don't think so um I don't think
that's right and that's it well you're
the dad listen look at this beautiful
crew neck you get it chris.com grow die
and you can also get it uh with the
special chris.com grower die my new
special my fifth special chris.com uh
but even more importantly well even more
importantly I'll be in Reading tonight
and even more importantly I'll be in
Phoenix and also Sacramento and Brea and
Oxnard and uh a bunch of different
places Albuquerque and go to.com
Sacramento and that's the most important
thing and then something that's even
less important is no is even more
important is the patreon.com luxury sign
up for that
less important is and evangelize that
and spread the word otherwise you're a
bad fan that's true and then of course
submit to my upcoming podcast the
private record go to the private
record.com follow us on Instagram and
Tik Tok subscribe on YouTube get all the
updates yeah man and leave a submission
thanks very much man
bye
hello
hello hello